while they're looking at is the
parametric equations of the conic
sections all four of them okay now we
already know most of these and so it
won't take you an effort to develop what
they are but what I want to demonstrate
is how these relate how you use the very
food so to begin what are the four
products in order again I can we start
with the circle what we do next the
ellipse is what happens when you stretch
that circle cut problem and that's what
happens when it gets so far it breaks
open and then the hyperbola is what
happens with the card which is actually
a double pair when you go sufficiently
far enough that you don't just get one
branch one intersection one section of
the code you actually wind up hitting
the other side and that's why there are
these two branches so let's think about
the Cartesian questions for all these
because we know all of these and we'll
just DISA standard forms okay so for
instance here we have x squared plus y
squared equals now we would usually say
us with Aspen because it's the radius
now we know the parametric equations for
this circle parametric equations are
equations for X and y that connect us
back to that single variable whatever
that may be okay now what variable did
we choose as a parameter for the sound
we chose an angle measured at the center
at the origin from the point against the
positive x axis very important we
defined what that is so then we said
okay well if I've got a radius of ices
on the unit circle right I mean it might
be but we don't know
so therefore instead just cos theta sine
theta I have to account for the fact
that I'm odd times further away from the
origin so that's where we get this room
like so also important to mention this
kind of arranged restriction on feeder
right it can't just go anywhere because
once you go right around a full
revolution you come back to where you
started
right so therefore history I would say
this is as extension to students the
ingredients rather than in degrees I can
get foot to 2 pi that's one full
revolution in theory there's nothing
stopping you going past 2 pi but the
whole point is to have one unique
defining factor for where you are on
your on your lockers right so therefore
if I restricted from 0 to PI everything
is really unique weird
ok so when we go to the ellipse what
changes ok we still have the x squared
plus y squared but we don't frame it in
these terms
doing.we 10% well there's a 1 over here
and then we get some denominators and we
have different denominators generally
speaking because if you don't have
different abilities you're back up in
cycle territory
yes so we're going to have a squared and
our B Square here now he's one of the
beauties of our parature forms right
because what this does is this takes the
unit circle right X square plus y
squared is 1 and it stretches the
horizontal out a times bigger and it
stretches the vertical path B times
begun right so instead of being a cos
theta sine theta
there's no artist because it doesn't
have a break yes right you're going to
be at x equals you'll be 8 Hertz further
away from the origin so you get a cos
theta and you'll be B to a further the
origin speaking vertically so you would
be a B Cynthia right and we have the
same restriction coming
goodbye so you can see I can just like I
can on the circle I can uniquely pick
any point like say there and I can take
all right just measure the angle from
that point to the positive that's pretty
bad like the positive x-axis you've got
an angle there that's the single down
you need to know where you are on the
ellipse that's with you on a parabola we
W the parameter a while ago this is the
form that we were generally used to make
the the parameter the parrot reflows
nice and neat right who remembers what
our X and our Y are when you talk about
the traveler to 1880 Smith very good 280
a t-square and it's worth remembering
that we've gone from angle territory to
here where you honestly could define it
by an angle but it is more useful to us
to define it as what is the primary
chose their gradient right because
anywhere the parabola right they every
point on the crab up boys has a
different gradient to every other point
on the parabola so therefore gradient so
I'll just T is Brady Brady is a great
thing to pick because it makes calculus
easier and all that now we come to the
hyperbola so we have a standard form x
squared on is where - and of course we
could switch around the expanded West
wait if you wanted the conjugate I don't
want to jump straight to what is the
form okay
the first thing I want to point out is
that here we had angles that we look to
gradient okay you have a look at this is
great going to be a good choice for
defining where you are on the locus and
the answer is no not really
because of all the crazy symmetry that
you've got right every point has a
gradient but it also has another point
that shares exactly
same great right on the opposite side of
the other quadrant so greedy it's going
to be no good how that angle what angle
work is every point uniquely defined by
angle there are it is thought nearly as
obvious versus the ellipse and versus
the circle but if I chicken parcels
relook at our diagram stability if I
take this and I say alright vision can
be argued and remembering that like this
isn't can we put the biggest so that
would be that's a zero right I figure oh
I probably have been hitting one point
on the longest to agree with that I can
spit all the way over to here I'm still
getting anyone put it on wall because
it's working out ankle will be fine it
read better than gradient for sure so
how do I then use that what what
equations it's obviously not going to
because of side so how do I arrive at
this okay now rather just handed to you
I want you to remember how we did it for
the circle in the circle on the center
what we measured was there's a point up
there on the lockers and then we said
okay well there's a right angle triangle
hiding there but you remember that
obviously we didn't study the circle of
any radius we started with the unit
circle right this is your extra women
this is your y coordinate okay that do
you see out of here how these guys
emerged do you see it right have a look
if I define that angle that we talked
about yellow as speed on right in that
right every triangle because X plus re
cos theta is equal to X 1 1 right I'll
taste it on hypotenuse so that's where
your x equals cost lady comes from and
then likewise you get this relationship
and of course you scale it up by r to
get to this arbitrary sir now that's
really nice because then if you carry
that forward from here right this of
course makes sense because you have this
kind of shape
this is quite an equation I should say
and the Pythagorean identity fits that
perfectly right side squared plus cos
squared I should say close square plus
sine squared equals one happy but we're
now trying to deal with this just for
the sake of simplicity I've taken the a
and B out of it because they've ledges
proportions right if I can understand
this everything will be fine